[Musique]
mais benjamin castaldi vous avez vous
fait rêver h et oui qu'est-ce qu'il ya
est-ce que vous avez déjà vendu une
maison très très chiant parce que je
sais que vous aviez une maison et on dit
tout aussi sa vie une maison à la
campagne
un truc de ouf par icade et vos
initiales sur dans le dahlia noir où je
perds coin non j'avais mi mai pour faire
une blague et j'ai même musicienne dans
le hammam
non non mais c'est plutôt maintenant
j'ai pu j'ai perdu était très bas il y
avait elle le faisait 1200 m² ouais il
200 m car il y avait cinq hectares de
terrain goulard vous été sur tf1
j'étais encore au téléphone quand j'ai
acheté oui c'est dingue évoque caravane
a fait combien le travail de maison
c'est sale et vous étiez récemment
non non c'était après j'étais à prêt
après j'ai une maison du côté de
deauville
ah ouais ben helli pas j'arrivais la
bande hélicoptère bien sûr il y avait un
héliport
non non aux benjamins on voulait non
mais c'est vrai que moi et donc vous
arrivé en hélicoptère à deauville
j'avais mis une manche à air vous savez
pour savoir d'où vient le vent dans les
bons coups qu'est ce que c'est que cette
histoire mais j'avais mis une manche à
air puisque quand on est content quand
on pilote va vous arriver en hélicoptère
dans la maison je savais pas mais c'est
pourquoi tous avec canon mais l'arrivée
we live en hélicoptère la maison
supercopter arrivée dans la maison et ça
fait quand même beau gosse il ya ta meuf
qui t'attend à la préparer les
cannellonis dans la cuisine tu arrives
en hélico hélicoptères à la maison ah
oui et maintenant quand tu arrives en
bio maintenant ça change des réponses
scooter mais j'arrive en hélicoptère de
ouf ça c'est important
pété les plombs ou est-ce que tu as du
tout franchement je me doutais qu'on est
histoire là d'hélico et d un
aller-retour un hélicoptère
bah c'est savoir 1500 euros de l'heure à
l'époque ça prenait comme maintenant
pour 40 minutes dont elle va garantir
les moitiés moitié machel mois moitié la
chaîne moitié mois mille cinq cents
euros je crois pas vous demander leur
aller lors de huit minutes
8 ça fait 48 d'aléas precarbi tu payes
leur tour basculer
donc ça c'est trop alors tu manques
installez vous voulez reverte a dit yu
la merde je n'aurais je ne mens pas
c'est triste c'est que le pilote est à
moscou il ya période avec vous il se
pose ou pau déchets vous les pilotes
vont loger où il dort avec vous et le
matin vous repartez travailler avec le
docteur donc il ya un prix il ya un prix
l'image seriez aussi le yoga
l'immobilier bah oui bien sûr on
commence à coûter cette affaire un
dirigeant ou 8 juan entre 3 gastaldi
nombreux mois
le taux était de 3,4 et bien sûr aller
retour ouais c'est fou ça et ça c'est
des trucs qu'on va garder mais on
connaîtra jamais ça mais à chaque
émission vous avez gagné des millions
d'euros vous avez un hélicoptère une
maison où elle au pognon je vous dis que
vous dites et que j'ai une question de
poser ma cause est ce que tu es pas plus
heureux maintenant beaucoup plus
non sans rigoler franchement mai au
local sous le nom mais voilà c'est je le
vois je vous jure qu'il est beaucoup
plus heureuse lord tout ben voila j'ai
payé j'ai appris voilà c'est tout va
bien tu t'en fous moi je m'en fou
maintenant et non et ça reviendra
peut-être un jour ou pas on sait pas
grave 8,6 et c'est magnifique ce que tu
dis pas ce que je te sens beaucoup plus
heureux maintenant qu'avant belles
aptitudes à vtt beaucoup plus sympa
maintenant qu'avant c'est toujours c'est
vrai parce que ne sont pas des gens
t'aiment plus maintenant qu'avant bah
oui parce que jamais mais du coup je
n'avais pas une bonne et à l'époque sur
tf1 j'avais une image qui me bizarre qui
me collait à la peau qui était à
l'envers de cette impression que tu peux
raconter les pas du tout je vous aurais
même que j'ai une fierté dans ma cage
auxerroise est une fierté des gens qui
ont connu il ya vingt ans pour rebondir
j'ai la chance j'ai pas changé j'ai pas
changer abattant à part de femmes à part
de femmes mais voilà après c'est vrai
que moi j'ai aimé j'ai aimé que la team
on osait avec brio ben voilà j'avais
jamais page avait pas une voiture dans
la veille huit ou neuf voix l'abbé
qu'est ce que ça peut faire aux tétons
quitté j'ai kiffé voilà c'était comme
dans l'autre l'argent j'ai volé personne
je vais gagner
c'est tellement pas me tuer j'aime à
tous crins mais voilà c'est pas grave ça
crame est plus que ce que tu avais quand
même tu as quand même plus que ce que tu
avais où tu cramer où tu l'enjeu quand
j'étais jeune je vivais très bien mais
j'ai passé j'ai eu quelques accidents de
vie vous le savez très bien sûr il va
pas revenir là mais la théorie tous très
heureux